a I'm L strong and this lecture is on
monsoons
and we're going to start out talking
about a couple of scenarios that will
lead up to monsoons and first I want you
to imagine that we've gotten an island
sitting out in the ocean and the ocean
let's say is 17 degrees
now the ocean has a very high heat
capacity which means it takes a lot of
energy to warm the ocean up and then
once the ocean is warm it takes a long
time for it to cool back down and and so
most places the ocean temperature is
pretty much the same day and night it
doesn't really change that much so for
this scenario the ocean is 70 degrees
and it's going to be 70 degrees in the
day and also at night but the island has
will be a fairly low heat capacity which
means that it's temperature is going to
dramatically change from day to night so
this is the daytime there's the Sun and
the Sun comes out and warms the island
and let's say he gets up to 80 to 85
okay so the temperature on the island is
warmer than that of the surrounding
water and the air starts to rise okay
the air starts to rise and if we think
about what happened when we did this
with cumuliform clouds of convection
let's say maybe we get some sort of
convective cloud above that the air
continues to rise then exits the cloud
right okay so for today the important
point is if you're making air rise off
this island there has to be other air
that comes and takes its place
so there has to be air moving in off the
ocean to replace the air that's rising
off the island so if you're standing
right here in this little picture you
would you would feel the sea breeze this
wind coming in off the ocean
and so you've got one coming in off the
ocean it rises the air we exits the
cloud and if we could follow it around
we would have some kind of convection
cell like this okay
so during the day we have air moving in
off the ocean moving in land and rising
above the island okay that's the day now
let's say same scenario but it's the
night
so now let's imagine what happens at
night so the Sun has gone down and we'll
draw here's the moon let's say and so
the water is still 70 but our island
because it has a low heat capacity you
know it warmed up quickly in the daytime
it's going to cool quickly at night and
let's say it cools down to 55 okay so
now this colder then the surrounding
ocean so what would happen is you would
have air that's rising on either side of
the island and there is air that is
replacing the rising air coming off of
the island so if you're standing here
you feel wind blowing out to sea okay so
this might rise and may or may not form
a cumuliform cloud but we set up a
circulation pattern that's exactly the
opposite of what we had in the daytime
so in the daytime we had air rising
because it was warmer than the air
around it at nighttime we have air
sinking over the island and air rising
on the other side of it so the the
circulation exactly
flipped okay so let's extend this idea
except now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to make the ocean and a continent
and now that instead of thinking of day
versus night let's think about summer
versus winter okay so if it is let's say
this is a 70 degree ocean and we have a
cut let's say it's the winter and the
continent is let's say 50 okay and this
is day and night they'll be there's
going to be a 24-hour cycle of
temperature but let's think about a
season here during this entire winter
season the continent is going to be
colder than the ocean so what'll happen
is air will rise over the warmer ocean
right and then this air over the
continent is going to come out to
replace the air that's rising
so again if you're standing here you've
got you experience this breeze coming
off the continent so if we could trace
this back we would see that there's this
this breeze coming down off the off the
continent out into the ocean and then
rising now what is this aerial ear like
well the way I've drawn this we've got
high elevations up here and we know that
higher you go the colder of the air so
this is probably pretty dry and cold and
as that air comes down the air warms so
sinking air warm so this air coming down
here hill is warming but it's not
getting any more moisture there's no
source of moisture so the only thing
that's changing as this comes down as
the relative humidity is decreasing so
you're making the air warmer
but the dew point makes the ratio of
staying the same so when you come down
here you've got low relative humidity
dry air okay and when I say warm that's
relatively speaking right this could be
this could all be really cold air of
course we said it's 50 degrees that's
not that cold but whatever temperature
this is this might be air that's way
below freezing and it's coming down the
continent and as it comes down at warms
doesn't necessarily mean it feels warm
to you it's just getting warmer
but the point is we've got cold dry air
coming down the continent going out to
sea okay so this is analogous to what
happens in a place like India okay so so
my continent here is maybe India and
this part up here are the Himalayan
mountains
so the Himalayan mountains that's that
big mountain chain between India and the
Tibetan Plateau so think of like Mount
Everest right you've got Mount Everest
is one mountain in this big chain of
really tall mountains you've got a
really you've got really tall mountains
up here on the way to Pakistan over here
and Tibetan Plateau so this then is
Indian Ocean and this is what India
experiences throughout the winter very
very dry conditions they've got air
sinking down off the Himalayans coming
down across the continent out into the
ocean where it then meets relatively
warm water and rises all right
so let's now think about so remember
just to make sure it's clear this is the
winter okay this is the winter so we're
gonna do the same scenario in the summer
okay so now I'm gonna draw another one
just like this one
and will say for the sake of argument
that the ocean is still 70 degrees but
now it is the summer and the continent
warms up more than the ocean so again
there's a there's a day/night cycle but
overall the continent is staying warmer
than the oceans so let's just say for
the sake of argument that it's a tea
over here okay so now we've got air
that's rising above the continent and
that is going to pull in air from the
ocean
now what's the air like that's over the
ocean well this is a pretty warm ocean
so this is high dewpoint air right so
back when we talked about the vaporators
you got warm body water you got a lot of
evaporation this is very humid air and
now you're you're pulling it over the
continent where the continent is warmer
than the ocean so you're gonna have
rising booms of air that lead to
thunderstorms and you're going to have
them all up and down I'm just drawing
this them in one spot but you're gonna
have this more and more as you go up the
continent so in fact you get all the way
up here remember this is the Himalayan
mountains up here Mount Everest all that
good stuff and as air rises up over
those mountains they're gonna make some
really extremely convective
thunderstorms up here right so as air
rises say above the Himalayan mountains
that's going to help pull this warm
humid air up over the continent so and
just to be clear you'd have rising air
on all these I'm just trying to point
out that you've got this big scale
circulation pattern which is that air is
being sucked in off the ocean
rising up over the Himalayan mountains
and rising up another places too but the
circulation has reversed so if you're
standing here in the scenario the wind
has cut is 180 degrees the other
direction in the winter it was moving
out towards the ocean in the summer it's
moving in from the ocean that's a
monsoon okay so the monsoon circulation
monsoon circulation simply means we had
a seasonal shift in the wind now because
there's an ocean out here and it's
pretty warm that seasonal shift in the
wind means we have a dry season and then
a wet season okay it doesn't have to be
that way in fact the very definition of
a monsoon is that it's just simply a
seasonal reversal in wind direction so
bulls one way part of the year and then
it blows from another way another part
of the year it could and usually does
lead to a wet season and dry season now
if you're from New Mexico we talked
about the monsoon as the wet time in the
summer and we'll talk about that in a
second but truly the definition of
monsoon just means the wind has a
reverse direction and it doesn't mean
it's reversed for a day or even a week
it's a seasonal thing right so it
completely reverses for months usually
that's what that's what the true monsoon
is so here's an example of what India
looks like before monsoon and after a
monsoon so here's two pictures taken
from the same location you can see they
stitched them together and you can see
that the huge difference in vegetation
between the dry period and the wet
period a lot of what we know about
modern weather was first figured out
when people were trying to understand
when in why the monsoon in India happens
so
because it's so dry for so long farmers
would like to know exactly when they
should plant their crops to take
advantage of when all this rain starts
so 100 years or so ago people were
really interested in trying to figure
out the timing of the monsoon and a lot
of the things that we've been talking
about so far like air pressure and all
that stuff was studied intensely to try
to figure out how to time them on soon
turns out even today you can't really
predict it very well so it's it's not
something that the actual reversal often
just occurs on one date we're just
suddenly the whole circulation shifts
and it turns out it's not even today we
still can't completely predict that so
I'm going to return to an animation we
saw last time and so we were talking in
the last lecture about how this ITCZ
corresponds to the to the warmest place
on earth so here we are in the first of
the year there is India right there
there's the Himalayan mountains right
there and we have the ITCZ here so I'm
going to move this further so in Howard
well we're in February right so just to
remind you what's happening along the
ITCZ you got easterly is coming in in
the northern hemisphere you got easter
bees coming in from the southern
hemisphere they are colliding right it's
Intertropical Convergence zone so
there's that convergence so right here
you can imagine the winds are coming
down off of Southeast Asia off of India
coming from the northwest moving towards
that equator right so I mean so towards
the ITCZ so we get in the spring
and notice what's happening the ITCZ is
creeping towards India and Southeast
Asia and then notice right there we're
actually coming in over India so from
their perspective they went from time
where the ITCZ was pretty far away to
the ITCZ
is actually on top
them and then throughout their their
summer it kind of lingers over the
continent and then fall it leaves again
okay so here's a couple graphical
illustrations of that so during the
winter the ITCZ is down here and if you
lived in northern Australia you have a
wet season right now because the ITCZ is
right above you but if you're in India
they have wind's coming mostly out of
the north down from the Himalayan
mountains and it's super dry by the time
summer rolls around the ITCZ
is up above India you've got wind coming
up from the south a lot of precipitation
but now it's left Australia and they're
getting wind coming from the south
coming from the middle of their
continent which is very dry so these two
locations have swapped their wet and dry
seasons now you can see this if you were
to make histograms bar graphs of
precipitation so in India so each one of
these is a month January February March
April cetera and then this is how many
millimeters of precipitation they get
each month so we're looking at this is
one location in India dry dry dry dry
and then all of a sudden in June you see
that bam huge increase of precipitation
that's the arrival of this ITCZ the
arrival of the quote-unquote the monsoon
and then it tapers down and then
disappears by the end of the year
Australia East northern part of
Australia is exactly the opposite you
can see this is their wet season and
then it disappears they have a super dry
summer and it's their winter because
seasons are reversed and then it gets
wet again at the end of the year ok so
these two are basically opposites of
each other and that's because of this
moving ITCZ just a reminder why is the
ITCZ moving because the seasons are
changed
so we're heating the northern hemisphere
they were heating the southern
hemisphere and the ITCZ is following the
warmest part of the ocean up and down
north and south so this animation shows
how the winds reverse in this part of
the world and what we're looking at is
about 15 years of wind and precipitation
data all averaged out so each one of
these little arrows shows you the
direction of the wind
the longer the arrow the faster the wind
right that's what the other doing and
then you see the precipitation are these
colors so if you think okay I'm gonna
stand right out here in India there's
the winter you can see the wind coming
down off the continent and it's dry and
boom there is the monsoon the winds
reverse wet and it returns back to dry
again you can see that band of rain
comes down and visits northern Australia
and then leaves it so these two
locations that we just showed in the
previous slide are having you know
reversed seasons
so when when's what the other ones dry
when the other ones dry the other ones
wet etcetera so we're going to look at a
little video here that's on YouTube that
was put together by some NASA scientists
and what they've done here is they've
been studying the monsoon using a lot of
satellite data and I'm mostly you're
just gonna let it play I'm gonna
interrupt it now and then just to make
obnoxious comments so let's start this
the monsoon is a seasonal rain and wind
pattern that was first described over
South Asia
you see the clouds blossoming here
during the summer part of the monsoon
for centuries people have known about it
but only recently have we received
enough data from satellites to really
describe what's going on okay so the
first thing is notice that down here
there is the date so June 14 2014 and
the time so what we're going to be
looking at is I mean images are being
updated every few minutes and so you'll
see the time whizzing by here day after
day after day also just make sure we're
clear this is all Doppler radar so this
is all precipitation they're showing in
the colors what you can see here is
moist air that has evaporated from the
ocean coming across India and providing
rainfall driving the monsoon season the
great thing about GPM is that it allows
us to see precipitating systems as a
whole over land and oceans and then as a
transition from one boundary to the next
all of this rainfall drives soil
moisture over land it's beneficial
because it promotes the economic
activity that people depend on for
example agriculture okay so just in case
you didn't catch it this is the soil
moisture color scheme over here so
they're looking at how the soil moisture
is changing throughout the reason rainy
season as well it fills the rivers which
provides water for human activity and
the natural environment as well as
transportation
if the rivers get too full of course it
becomes flooding at first the floods you
see here are fairly minor and
broad-scale but then they concentrated
in a few Wiggly lines which are the
river basins for example in central
eastern China in mountainous regions
when the ground becomes saturated due to
heavy rains it can lead to landslides
landslides kill thousands of people
every year and are primarily triggered
by rainfall they are especially common
within the Himalayan region each monsoon
season one really cool way to look at
the monsoon is to do a split screen and
look at the summer and the winter at the
same time in the summer the wind is
blowing onshore bringing the moist rain
Laden air into the continent in the
winter time it blows off the continent
now those winds are basically driven by
temperature differences between the
ocean and the land and where the land is
nice and warm the air expands and it
draws in the moist precipitation from
the ocean waters but in the winter time
it's very cold and you can see that the
moisture then it goes from the continent
back into the oceans okay so this is
what we talked about earlier with the
how the witness shift direction what
they're showing here are this is
temperature so you'll see that as it is
it moves from day night day night day
night you can see the temp the continent
getting warmer and then cooler warmer
than cooler and it doesn't also in the
winter the difference is on average the
continent is still warmer than the ocean
and over here on average the continent
is colder than the ocean so if you watch
these two you can see how yes the
continent gets warmer in the day and
cools off at night but the difference
between the two is how it compares to
the ocean so that's what those Fox
wedding colors mean over the past 50
years or so satellites have been used to
measure precipitation all
our earth with that data set we're able
to understand that monsoons occur not
only in South Asia and India but in
other parts of the world as well for
example Africa where the temperature
gradient is between the Atlantic Ocean
and the Sahara Desert the wind blows
from the moist Atlantic Ocean on to West
Africa providing the moisture for the
precipitation some of these westward
moving storms provoke hurricanes over
the Atlantic that occasionally make it
to the US southwestern North America
also has a summertime monsoon you see
high soil moisture in regions where
there's a lot of precipitation in
western Mexico later in the season this
extends up into the southwestern US and
the southern hemisphere has a monsoon as
well this occurs in the Northern
Hemisphere winter which is a southern
hemisphere summer when Australia is
warmer than the Ocean to the north
having a better understanding of the
global water cycle and monitoring
changes over time is important for
society for our everyday lives and our
long-term future so near the end of that
video they talked about the monsoon in
the southwestern part of the United
States and of course that's what we
referred to as the monsoon and as far as
monsoons go ours is really pretty wimpy
and monsoon purists would say that in
fact it hardly counts as a monsoon
compared to ones like India and Africa
but for us it's important because it
represents half of our annual rainfall
so we're going to talk about that and
back when we talked about humidity and
dew point we were talking about how the
dew point in New Mexico changes a lot
depending on the wind direction so if
you have wind coming out of the West or
the the North you we typically have very
low dew points because the air is coming
from a pretty cold source whereas if we
have winds coming from the East or the
South of the southeast we typically have
relatively high dew points because it's
come somewhere from a pretty warm
and source so the big picture about the
New Mexican monsoon is that through most
of the year our winds are like this
they're coming out of the West they are
we were in the westerlies and then for
July August a little bit September we
get a couple months where the winds very
weakly kind of reverse and we get a weak
easterly or southeasterly or maybe even
a southerly flow and that's what
triggers our summertime thunderstorms
that we call them on soon so to explain
why this happens I'm going to go over a
new concept that's a that's kind of
abstract but we kind of have to cover it
to understand the next maps we're gonna
see let's imagine that we've got the
we're going to cut a cross-section of
the atmosphere that those are supposed
to be trees and I have a blob of cold
air and cold air is pretty dense and
right next to it I've got a blob of warm
air and warm air if you warm up air it
expands so my blog the warm air is more
expanded and let's imagine that I was
gonna get into a balloon well first of
all let's just think about this is even
though I've got a ground in trees let's
imagine we're at sea level down here
what's the air pressure at sea level
it's about a thousand thirteen millibars
okay
so back when we talked about air
pressure let's imagine again into a
balloon and I got my barometer and I go
up and I'm trying to find how high I
have to go to get to 700 millibars okay
and so let's say I find that spot and it
turns out it's about right here okay so
go up in the balloon
find the 700 millibar level and plot it
on a map and I take many balloon rides
to find this and when I get to the warm
air what I would find is because the
cold air is more dense and compacted I
get to the 700 millibar level sooner
than if I was in a balloon and
into the warm air I have to go farther
up to get to that 700 millibar level so
it might be something like this and we
call this height in this case to the 700
millibar level we call this the geo
potential height now that's fancier term
that we need in this class we can just
imagine how high do you have to go to
get to a certain pressure level I could
make one for a 500 millibars I'd have to
go higher up I could make it for
whatever level I wanted but in this case
I'm going up to 700 millibars point is
yeah if I were to do this experiment in
a balloon I would have to go further up
to get to the 700 millibar because that
air is more expanded because it's warmer
so we're gonna see this on a map in a
second we would call this area up here a
high and this area down here a low so
like we talked about air pressure you
had highs and lows it's similar to that
but it's talking about a different thing
the surface is high the geopotential
height surface is what we call this as
high and the height surface is low okay
so we got to do this because I want to
we're not going too deep here I just
want to explain this too so that the
next map will make sense so we're going
to look at some maps of this what we
call the 700 millibars surface and I put
these maps on learn they're also on my
website and what they've done here is
for example this first one february 1st
to February 28th so that's looking at
every day in the month of February for
the last 30 years averaging where that
700 millibars height level is imparting
as contours so here for example 31 40 ok
so what does that mean
so this map and all the ones we're gonna
look at are 700 millibar height how far
up do you have to go above sea level to
get to 700 millibars it doesn't tell you
this but the units are in meters so I'd
have to go up three thousand one hundred
forty meters to get to 700 millibars and
if I stayed on this line that's exactly
going to be 700 millibars over here the
height would be three thousand one
hundred and thirty meters 2010 so you
can see that the height is going down as
these as we move to the north why is
that because the air up here is pretty
cold so it's compressed air down here is
pretty warm so it's expanded so we can
put in some highs and lows here just
like a pressure map so at the top here
the numbers are smaller smaller smaller
there's a low I'm gonna fit right there
and then here I've got a high right here
okay so this low is due the fact that
the Arab there's just really cold and
compressed this high this kind of loop
here is due to one of the subtropical
highs and this one is called the Bermuda
high which I'm just gonna write down
here the Bermuda high and this high
pressure system will as we see will
change just like that there's one over
here the Pacific subtropical high which
isn't really showing so much on this map
here okay the rules for which direction
winds go are the same as they were for
air pressure clockwise around a high
counterclockwise or on the low in the
northern hemisphere okay so here's the
high so I've got clockwise around this
high parallel to the contours so my wind
is like this and then over here it's
still in that same general trend and
that it's a clockwise sense around the
high
counterclockwise sense around the the
low and if I were to just kind of draw
some of these in what I see is basically
the winds are going parallel to the
contours and time and time again in this
part of the country that gets you air
that's come and kind of down from the
west-northwest direction right so in New
Mexico we just think about New Mexico we
get wind comes straight out of the West
here okay and we've got westerlies in
fact the whole country's in westerlies
at this point and only down here do we
see anything that's kind of easterly's
way down in here
okay so we can move on to March and it's
pretty much exactly the same the whole
country is still in the westerlies so I
will draw a few arrows here to
illustrate but our winds are still
coming out of the West so they're cold
and they're dry okay so now we're moving
on to April here and we can see that we
have a high down here that's our Bermuda
high we still have a low up in here and
we still have there's really nothing
much has changed too much yet we still
have counterclockwise around the high
and everybody is still pretty much in
the westerlies including us okay so we
are we still have wind coming out of the
west all right we get to May okay so
same kind of thing we don't really see
it down here but the Bermuda high is
kind of lingering down here and again
for us New Mexico still nothing much has
changed except we're starting to see
this little dip down here
okay so our winds are coming out of the
West but they're actually starting to
come sort of across this the northern
part of the Gulf of California right
here and it's possible that we might be
picking up some moisture here but if we
go further back it's still coming off
the cold Pacific Ocean okay so so far
nothing much has changed yet we're still
in the westerlies and now I'm gonna
break it up so the maps we've been
seeing so far or once a month I'm gonna
break it down into one every two weeks
now so this is the first half of June
okay here's our Bermuda high it's
getting stronger why is it getting
stronger
same reason the Pacific subtropical high
gets stronger in the summer we're
heating the northern part of the
hemisphere and it's getting stronger and
it's growing so here it is here's the
high and we are low is off the page here
somewhere clockwise around the high okay
so I'm gonna go around this way parallel
to the contours okay so notice that if I
were to kind of draw this out Southeast
Texas is starting to to change its wind
direction right there moving out of the
westerlies we are still coming out of
the West but we still have this little
dip here where but potentially getting
some moisture from Gulf of California
here all right boo rest of the country
still pretty much in the westerlies okay
let's go the last half of June now our
Bermuda high is now stronger and so we
can see the influence of that
here's counterclockwise road rotation
clockwise clockwise we have a funny
little nose here but it's still
clockwise okay notice what's happening
so at the end of June if we follow our
error trajectory back in time
it's possible that some of it could have
come from the Gulf of Mexico except I
had to travel all the way across Mexico
and they come around this way northern
Mexico still getting it out of the
Pacific but we're starting to see a
transition to air that's coming from a
different place well if if it had to
come all the way across Mexico it
probably lost most of its moisture on
the way here so it's still not really
humid air for the most part and if you
if you know anything about the monsoon
you know that in general it starts
usually about the first week of July and
we're getting really close right we're
near the end of June
ok so now we're going to move on to
beginning of July ok so now here's our
high and we've got clockwise rotation
around the high and notice what we've
got here we've now transitioned so that
the wind that's coming into New Mexico
if we trace it back has its origins in
the Gulf of Mexico and unlike we saw in
the previous one it doesn't have to go
all the way out to the Pacific and loop
back some of it looks like it has a
direct route across new across Mexico
and right into New Mexico and that is
the trigger of our monsoon so we are now
out of the westerlies and we're starting
to get flow that's maybe southerly flow
maybe a little bit of a southeast
component remember these are averaged
over 30 years so the wind can change day
to day a little bit this is what happens
when you average over you know a
two-week period for 30 years
ok so then we get to the end of July and
here's our Bermuda high so you notice
that the Bermuda high over time has been
migrating to the north so that's what
the Pacific subtropical high it's
migrating to the north it's out its out
here so
we're not on our map really but that's
what's causing this this shift so again
we can draw clockwise around the high
and it's pretty clear from this now that
any wind that's coming this direction
has its origins from the Gulf of Mexico
right so you've got circulation coming
around entering New Mexico straight from
the Gulf of Mexico so we've got high dew
points now monsoon is in full swing
usually okay
so and in August is pretty much more the
same story here's our high here's our
rotation around that high now one thing
that's I want you to notice that's
different here if I go back to say June
do you see how close the contours are to
each other remember when we talked about
wind and we said that the wind direct
the wind speed is proportional to the
pressure gradient so the closer these
are together the faster the wind goes
that was with pressure gradient it's the
same thing with this height gradient so
if I go to where we are now notice we
see almost and there's no contours
across the the entire state at all
there's a very low height gradient also
we could say there's a very low pressure
gradient which means that the winds
themselves are very very weak okay so
even though I'm drawing it in these
loops like this it's a very weak wind
okay it's a very very weak wind which is
one of the things that makes purists say
this isn't really a very proper monsoon
the winds just kind of
I in the moisture kind of trickles
upwards towards us but anyway let's keep
going so that's beginning of August and
now we're getting to the end of August
and what's happening now is our high
pressure the Bermuda high starting to
make its way back to the South okay and
our Pacific subtropical high which is
out here in the ocean is also starting
to make its way back but we're getting
that clockwise rotation and so we are
still if I kind of draw in some arrows
here we're still getting moisture out of
the Gulf of Mexico for the most part
here then we get to so beginning in
September and we're still in it
now our monsoon on average typically
dies out about the middle of September
ok so here we were in the beginning of
September here or in the last half of
September and so here we've got our high
and it's kind of a weird-shaped high but
we're getting this and this ok so notice
what happened the northern part of New
Mexico is now if you follow it around is
coming out of the Pacific Ocean
maybe the southeast part in New Mexico
still getting some from Gulf of Mexico
but it's still having to travel quite a
ways to get there that's different than
just a couple weeks before when we had
wind coming across pretty much straight
from the Gulf of Mexico here so by that
when you start making the transition
back to moisture from the Pacific
monsoon is over
okay and so somewhere about halfway
through September we stopped getting
those daily thunderstorms I'm gonna say
the monsoon is over okay and now when we
move on to October so that Bermuda high
is now centered again it's marching its
way south and it's getting weaker so we
have this this and now we're pretty much
back into the westerlies okay so in
October we're back in the westerlies and
then it just goes back to the kind of
where we started so here we are late
October and we are right back where we
were before the monsoon so why do we
have them on soon we have a monsoon
because this shifting subtropical high
migrates north and south with the
seasons and it changes the circulation
pattern around it so when it gets to
about beginning of July this is situated
far enough north that we start to get
into a little bit of an easterly
southeasterly flow and we're out of the
westerlies finally and then that allows
some cumulonimbus to occur and then a
couple months after that it starts
migrating its way back down and we go
back into the westerlies and we're back
to dry air so back when we talked about
dewpoint we looked at one of these
graphs and this is dew point in
Albuquerque at the airport during the
monsoon season so there's a blue line
and a red line the blue line is the dew
point as recorded in 2013 the red line
is the average of the dew point in the
previous 30 years okay so let's just
look at the red line first the red line
again
for 30 years and what we see so so
dewpoint is on the the y-axis so 30
degrees that would be in Fahrenheit and
so in June or typically in the
westerlies and so we have pretty low dew
points and on average it ramps up and
ramps up until we get to this 47 degree
line this green line right here and the
weather service here has kind of picked
that line it's kind of arbitrary but the
idea is that if we have three days of
dew points above 47 degrees three
consecutive days then we're going to
call that the beginning of the monsoon
and if you average the last 30 years
that comes out to be this line right
here is July 11th so right around JA
July 10th or 11th or so is about three
days beyond where that red line crosses
the Green Line so you'll read about the
average date the average start or the
New Mexican monsoon is about July 10th
or 11th that's where it comes from just
averaging 30 years of dew point and then
usually our dew point stays above that
47 degree line and then a dips back down
so this is September 9th right around
there and then it continues to go
downhill as we go back into the
westerlies okay so that's average right
averaged over 30 years it gives you kind
of a smooth red line now the blue line
is what happens in an actual year in
this case this is 2013 and so you see a
lot of Wiggles up and down that
correlate to wind direction so when it's
high that means we had wind coming out
of the East higher dew points when it's
low that's due wind coming out of the
west or north that's low dew points and
so you can see that leading up to the
actual monsoon the winds are changing
direction right so we've got easterlies
westerlies easterlies westerlies and
finally it kind of gets into the
easterlies and stays there for a while
within the monsoon
our little variations where the winds
shift back and forth a little bit but we
hit but at least in 2013 we you know for
the most part we stayed above that Green
Line throughout most of the monsoon
season so throughout most of the summer
our dew point was hovering you know over
50 degrees or so you see a couple places
where dip down a little bit and so we
call those monsoon breaks usually their
correspondent with times when we have
either a high pressure center or the
winds come out of the west or the north
and we have a lack of cumulonimbus and
our dew points go down and then on this
particular year it kind of had a crazy
end looks like we had a lot of unusually
humid air in middle September and
finally dies you know somewhere here
near you know last half of September
well every year is different
so here's 2014 we see we had a couple
really pretty significant monsoon breaks
everywhere you see this referred to this
as a monsoon burst which means that we
have air with extra water vapor in it
and often that leads to more
cumulonimbus if we go to sea 2015 here's
an interesting one here's 2016 so we had
what's called an early start to the
monsoon so three days after the Green
Line there's one two three monsoon
starts and it's before it's before July
so if you look at the newspaper
headlines back then they were super
excited that the monsoon has started
early and so we have several days of
monsoon activity and then it crashes and
we see that the dew point went way down
super dry air right dewpoints like 15
degrees that's that's like middle of the
winter air and it's stayed low and
didn't rebound back to normal until this
is what July 21st before we're back to
kind of average so we had a really
basically got a completely dry month
that it rained right in the end of June
very beginning of July and then the rest
of the July was pretty much
dry before we bounce back to normal
everyone soon season is different has a
unique monsoon break or monsoon burst
pattern and it's only by averaging every
year over and over and over do you get
that kind of smooth red line that shows
you what the average dew point was so if
we made precipitation histograms kind of
like the ones that we saw from India and
Australia this is what it looks like so
the way you read these is this first bar
is January and then it goes through the
air and the last bar is December
so notice say along the west coast here
in Mexico and California you've got wet
relatively wet winters dry summers ok so
nurse ed wet winter dry summer that's
what we call Mediterranean climate we
talked about this last time that Pacific
subtropical high forms out here it makes
it really dry along the coast in the
summer and then the the mid-latitude
cyclones come through and make it wet in
the in the winter we see the range tidal
effects over here in Nevada it's pretty
much dry all year round so in Las Vegas
but notice what happens when you get
over here you see a completely different
patterns so here in Hermosillo
it's super super dry super super dry and
then about June July BAM we get a big
increase in precipitation and then the
tapers off or this one or this one okay
those are classic monsoon patterns so
here in the states we've got two saan
very very dry dry dry dry the driest
month in there is June and then BAM the
wettest month is July the month after
that's where that monsoon circulation
starts so we go from the westerlies to
the easterlies or the South easterlies
and suddenly Tucson gets their monsoon
start so monsoon precipitation can be
noticed on these histograms with this
kind of pattern where it gets super dry
and also
spike or a said with a circulation
suddenly shifted in fact there's this
dotted line right here that says 50% so
this right through in here that means
the area within here gets 50% of their
annual precipitation during the monsoon
and so what we think of is our monsoon
is really a Mexican phenomenon in fact
decades ago it was referred to in
scientific literature as the Mexican
monsoon and later people in the u.s.
renamed it they called it the North
American monsoon so we kind of stole it
from the Mexicans but what do you know
so these contours show how much of your
annual precipitation comes during the
summer so this number you're 60 percent
of your annual precipitation falls in
the summer 55 percent 50 45 so notice
that of all the states in the Union
we have the biggest blob of monsuno
precipitation meaning that for New
Mexico roughly half of our precipitation
falls in the summer due to this
monsoonal circulation but for the most
part it's actually a Mexican phenomenon
we just get just the dregs of it up into
New Mexico Arizona gets a little bit too
you